mm go in rice - purify and welcome to
the best game ever made
it's called scramble Oz I got a new
character but something happens when he
walks I don't know what's up with it all
right let me ride on my harmless snake
and we're gonna solve the rest of them
on this map let's start with that I
start with this gentleman over here what
can I help you with I'm a horse what are
they doing
I did something I solved something I
don't even know what I saw what else
this man needs my help my nose isn't
good enough to sniff out your efforts
alone how about a dog
oh wait doesn't pick sniff ugh chuckle
[Music]
now yes it looks like [ __ ] what it what
is truthful exactly what is that Doug do
that tiny little guy forgot the dog [ __ ]
oh wow this thing this poo needs my help
this isn't comfortable to sleep create
something better for the backpackers all
right how about a bed I don't know yeah
fireworks and [ __ ] yeah what's that
alright these people need my help and
then I think that's all for this area
what do you want my kite is stuck in the
tree oh yeah I stole this kite [ __ ]
sorry man I don't have your kite anymore
I have a kite and you don't have one is
he wanted alright what is it he's
suicide oh there it is
they're mine [ __ ] is he doing you see
I'm drugs
alright I'll pick this one up and I'll
give it to that guy here you go
I just want to punch mushrooms
apparently good good good for your man
all right these people oh yeah these
[ __ ] people
I hate got better yeah what a great idea
I got going here right of all Yankee
let's complete the final form of the
army catch you go can I ride now I can
oh what a shame
alright I'll just get my own honest
thing well I don't have a face anymore
it looks like a merge of a horse and
young cat alright let's give this to him
my kite all right you can have it
[Music]
there you go douche what is left we got
one land Dundas ty oh it's here help
Jack from cutting down this tree no no
no no he did it anyway he shot down a
tree I underestimated Jack's badassness
god damn let's make him harmless save
the arse
now [ __ ] off ya [ __ ] all right are we
done with this area no we're not
we need this one help scout earnest man
[Music]
best dance ever and you [ __ ] know it
alright I got hey help Scout earn his
merit badge first give him a tool to
carve in his line a pen a knife whoa
he's good
wait how do you expect out of that [ __ ]
fire Safety's next give the scouts
something to put the dummy on fire X
thing we sure holy [ __ ] I spell that
right day yeah I'm awesome
and I'm a horse now that fires odd give
the Scout something to fix the dummies
once a medic it literally uses a medic
what time to target shooting start by
giving Scout proper safety equipment
a force field I don't know on are more
now time to give a huge bow
you're welcome hi but what about me
that guy's out okay you don't what crazy
[ __ ] you nearly killed me
well I'm taking this Oh - cube zombie a
mummy or whatever hmm let me grab that
[ __ ]
let me grab that [ __ ] Rene libros let's
dance let's jam like Sam that sounds
nice to have that down I only got one
night now
all right hey doing how you doing oh
yeah was playing like we made it and we
finish it a lot of them honestly we need
40 for that one I think we have like 37
or some [ __ ] we've never been in and for
a fault
so we might as well go there welcome to
an F for our Falls now dead fishes
crying bit oyster Twilight is that it
crying [ __ ] oh [ __ ] it is hello
friend I can't feel the sunlight by
River create something to help me turn a
supernova now should make you tan no son
how about I
vitamin d3 he died a disgusting well I'm
taking that mustache my mustache haha
I'm wearing it on my legs
everyone knows people who wear mustaches
let's get pit by out there oh it crashed
it crashed because I did that hello frog
a over it's froggy play something in
between these logs to help me cross the
river whoa
[ __ ] love how I swim all right a row
yes this is not really working out as
planned not gonna lie but I a I got a
frog um okay what do you guys want she's
dead
please reunite me with my love let's
make her into a ghost he's back what the
[ __ ] what about him I'm gonna piss a
come on get it get over yourself um yeah
you can have a frog well that didn't
work
rear actor I wrote resurrector this
might work let's say it doesn't look
like it's working ok we need to fix her
somehow
I'll go to another one meanwhile hello I
want to dance but I don't have a beat to
follow
how about Justin Bieber a judging beaver
alright boombox my god
rain dance holy [ __ ] Justin Bieber come
with me
it's the only Justin Bieber what is this
monkeys one gorillas we only allow
gorillas in a trip and you are no
gorilla but I don't want to be in your
trip well how about this gorilla you can
have heaven it's riding in I love
building towers of days I could the [ __ ]
seriously what the [ __ ]
hello Jenny oh man I gotta try this nice
hat bro no you ruined my gorillas get
the [ __ ] outta my gorillas hey gorilla
what are you doing
that's my rainbow card Oh what the [ __ ]
baby like crazy awesome Bieber let's go
we go realize this game is so [ __ ]
stop park my car please Jesus that guy's
crazy hello am i a gorilla yet am i
doing it right an adjective gorilla
gorilla 'n holy [ __ ] that way even
justin bieber became a gorilla
oh we became faster now what the [ __ ]
well we can flying [ __ ] whoa
I love being a gorilla and I told you to
park my car
alright hey Dad how could you eat a bit
why would you eat a billboard seriously
what the [ __ ]
all right gorillas ins away Wow what the
[ __ ] is going on help me sail again okay
let's make it rain here that's not
working oh wait it is working wait throw
I throw a banana at it it's not it sank
[ __ ] huh extinguished that's not good
working yay hey gorilla
don't you dare drown Justin Beaver did I
stop attacking that poor bud
like what the [ __ ] is going on seriously
please reunite me with you wait who is
there love maybe that's bull or
I don't worry alright first I'm sorry
but that's all I have today dr. berry
you like this guy come to read today and
I'll see you next episode
Oh mommy love you brother say awesome
[Music]
can I go here Calabar